okay let's get back to the phones at 6 1
7 8 3 0 47 50 a lot of very high quality
calls today let's see if we can keep it
going with our caller from the seven six
zero area code who's calling today from
seven six zero hi David
this is Amy from San Diego hey Amy
what's going on so kind of piggybacking
off the last caller he started making me
think about Edward Snowden and I'm also
a Bernie supporter and I'm wondering if
you think Bernie would do anything that
would allow Edward to come home I
actually don't know how you feel about
him but about Edward in particular but
yeah I you know I don't it's very hard
to know would anyone have predicted when
Donald Trump was running for president
that he was going to get involved in
whatever the person's name was that Kim
Kardashian mentioned to him or whatever
like no I mean there was that that was
pretty unpredictable so it's
unpredictable too it's hard to say what
it is that Bernie would or wouldn't get
involved in but I've not seen and
correct me if I'm wrong if you know
otherwise I've not seen any evidence
that Edward Snowden is high on Bernie's
list of priorities yeah I don't know I
guess for me personally I just gotten
into like the mass surveillance and
realizing how big it is in the country
and all of that and but yeah you're
right I don't think what would you like
to see happen with Edward Snowden well
mainly I just for one note as I said
like he would come home if he had got a
fair trial
and so the reason he's not getting a
fair trial is because he's tried with
the Espionage Act so I mean I don't want
him to get tried with anything but I
mean I guess Bernie could lower or
change whatever I don't know yeah I mean
listen either there is any path to
Edward Snowden not being charged
if he comes to the United States I think
that I've read some opinions that say
espionage act is really you're
interpreting it pretty loosely if you
apply it to Edward Snowden and maybe it
should not apply I think that's a
conversation to have but I don't see any
way that he comes back and just has no
charges gotcha okay yeah no you're right
but I think that's reasonable I think
that that makes sense all right Amy
thank you for the call great to hear
from you
thank you David all right take care